merci merci monsieur le président
l'union européenne ne se porte pas bien
du fait de ses propres faiblesses et de
l'absence récurrente de volonté
politique de ses dirigeants nationaux et
ce alors que nous sommes confrontés à
des défis de plus en plus lourds crise
de notre économie et de l'emploi crise
des réfugiés et des migrants terrorisme
guerre à nos frontières et départ du
royaume uni et tout cela à un moment où
gouvernants américains et russes jouent
chacun leur propre partition avec tous
les risques que cela comporte
ce moment difficile il devrait être une
exigence pour l'europe et les européens
à agir
l'europe doit enfin se décider à exister
par elle-même
je plaide devant vous pour un sursaut
européen
c'est le moment d'avancer à la
refondation de notre union
c'est le moment de mettre le paquet pour
une croissance durable et de mettre en
oeuvre au sein de la zone euro
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale et la
gouvernance politique que nous attendons
depuis bien longtemps
c'est le moment de parler d'une seule
voix pour peser enfin en syrie en irak
pour la sortie de crise et de guerre et
sur la scène diplomatique du monde
c'est le moment de se mettre autour de
la table pour jeter les bases d'une
véritable politique de sécurité et de
défense européenne
et c'est le moment vous l'avez dit
monsieur le premier ministre de mettre
en oeuvre une politique commune digne de
ce nom
en matière d'asile et de migration et de
développement
les citoyens européens attendent que
leurs dirigeants soit enfin à la hauteur
de tous ces défis la responsabilité de
ces derniers est donc clairement engagés
ils ont l'obligation d'agir et de
réussir je vous remercie